hello everyone and welcome back to the
video World Cup we are in the second
game of the quarterfinals with another
uh very exciting game it is Magnus
Carlsen versus gookish and the Magnus
defeated Lucas with the black pieces so
now gookish needs a win to bounce back
as the title suggests no spoilers let's
see what happened here Magnus has the
white pieces and he opens with Ponte E4
we have Pawn to C5 uh gookish Ops for
the Sicilian Defense as one always
should when one needs a win and C3
Magnus goes for the alapan variation
although Magnus really loves to play the
open Sicilian uh he does go for the
alapan here probably he thought that
maybe it was something that Lucas was
expecting a little bit less uh so Pawn
to D5 e captures and D5 Queen captures
and pawn to D4 uh the the sort of main
line of the alapin Knight to F6 with
Knight to F3 and Ponte E6 now we have
Bishop to E2 and now C captures on D4 we
have C captures Knight to the C6 and we
have castles here so those are all very
standard moves being played many many
times Bishop seven Knight the C3 forces
the queen to move back and much like in
the Scandinavian defense you could bring
the queen to d8 to A5 or my favorite
pawn queen to D6 which is what gookers
does we have Queen B5 now pushes the
queen further back and now Bishop to F4
threatening Knight to C7 check so
Knights the D5 attacks the bishop and
defends the C7 square and now Bishop to
G3 and the good thing about this
position for Magnus is that a white uh
on the very top level white never lost a
game uh playing this and uh uh pretty
much all the games where white did play
this ended in a draw there is one game
and I had to look very very deep and far
from 1994 where you did for a unit
Polgar defeated Sergey divyakov with the
white pieces from this position but
pretty much all of the other top tier
games ended in a draw so uh seemingly an
easy to hold position it will be quite a
challenge for gookish to take down
Magnus Carlsen from this position uh we
have castles and now Rook the C1 with
Bishop to D7 nicely continuing
development and now Knight back to C3
and here Google goes for Queen to B6 he
says all right I'm gonna put pressure on
B2 uh what do you play here and Magnus
could decide for a couple of ideas here
let's say Knight A4 attacks the queen
defends the B2 Pawn let's say queen A5
and Knight to the C5 now attacks the B7
pawn and the bishop and let's say Bishop
captures Pawn captures and now Queen
characters on A2 is this something that
the magnets would want to play uh
definitely if if he was playing a normal
game in a normal tournament uh where he
would play some like Bishop to D3 put
some immense pressure on the uh on the
on the black king maybe you can even
later on re-maneuver The Rook to the
attack I mean for the price of one Pawn
you are getting quite a lot but he only
needs a draw this game so he plays
Bishop to C4 uh and okay Knight back to
F6 by gookash and now only now Knight to
A4 we have Queen to A5 and now Knight
the C5 so it's a similar position but
now gokish just brings the bishop back
Bishop to C8 he doesn't want to trade
and uh okay the bishop returns to the
starting position uh but uh of course he
will play B6 kick with the Knight and
then re-maneuver his Bishop to this long
diagonal Magnus plays A3 and by doing so
he is offering a pawn but can guish
actually capture this Pawn well there
are many great moves here and I'm just
going to show you two of them Knight
captures on D4 is one so okay you can
grab the pawn what was magnus's idea of
course the idea spawned to B4 and now
after Knight captures an F3 check Queen
captures and queen to B6 he will play
Rook after D1 and as you can see Magnus
has completed his development for the
price of one Pawn he has B4 played and
the Knight that is on an excellent
Square Bishop is excellent the bishop
can be re-maneuvered to this diagonal
you will have constant pressure against
the the black king all sorts of
checkmating threats uh easily to
re-maneuver the Rooks uh uh to the
king's side so I mean for the price of
one Pawn this is definitely something
you play so Mukesh uh not about to go
for that the move he could play his Rook
to d8 but it's such a funny looking move
because after Bishop to D3 which is a
direct counter to this Rook to the
eighth moon now of course you cannot go
after the pawn because if you capture
then uh well afterward captures You're
Gonna Play Bishop captures on H7 check
and pick up the Rook on D4 but what you
can play is play this Rook to D5 move
and now you are preparing Queen to d8
with the Rook on D5 and you will have
excellent pressure on the D4 Pawn so
this is how maybe uh should have uh
continued here but after Pawn to A3 he
went back Queen to 88 and now Magnus uh
well this is a perfect opportunity for
him to play Bishop at the back to A2 and
re-maneuver the bishop to B1 and have
constant pressure against that black
king but he played Bishop to B5 here
instead and uh when he played this he
was not happy with himself I guess he
saw Google schneck's move here and
before gookish played it and he didn't
even get up from the board he was just
you know in a thinking position uh which
is something that you don't do after you
play a move it's something you do after
your opponent plays a move but he
obviously saw what googas will play and
he started thinking preemptively so
Queen to B6 uh this is uh the move
because Quinta did was not the best move
so here basically Magnus gave Lucas a
chance to go back with Tempo and now
Force Magnus to react to this now you
either Captain C6 which doesn't look all
that impressive or you go to Bishop to
A4 and again maybe too aggressive or
white here because again Magnus only
needs a draw here you have to give up
the B2 Pawn now you play rookie one you
build up the A3 Pawn now you do a rook
lift Rook D3 and now let's say queen to
B4 and now uh look at what what you
would have to find all the way from that
position Knight the A6 attacks the queen
of course if you capture then uh then
the Knight on C6 will hang so Queen to
A5 and now look at this Knight the C 7
attacks The Rook here and after Rook the
B8 look at this point to D5 and you
can't even imagine what's happening here
but the black queen is being trapped and
you have to be very very precise for
that not to happen let's say we're up to
d8 and now what do you play of course
the bishop captures on C6 uh you're
gonna capture that Knight and after B
captures You're Gonna Play Knight to E5
and uh What uh what do you even play
here Bishop to B7 otherwise there's this
massive Fork here going after the two
Rooks and the Queens are gonna play
Bishop to B7 now Knight to C4 attacks
the black queen and what do you play
Queen to C5 okay then Pawn to D6 and you
you have a pass Pawn on D6 so okay I
mean this is complete Madness but if you
can uh find all of the nice moves you
can play Bishop to A4 of course it's too
much for a human to ask so upon the A4
by Magnus and now comes Rook to d8 uh
and now Queen to E2 Magnus is down to 27
minutes on the clock uh has 43 minutes
it's on the clock so Luke is doing much
better and Magnus seemingly offering the
D4 Pawn but where's the catch well the
catch is that if you capture it now then
Knight captures Rook captures and now
Knight to B3 attacks the rook and where
do you put the Rook again a funny line
where the black queen might get trapped
is that if you move the Rook back the
queen has no squares you're just gonna
attack the queen with Pawn to A5 and the
queen is trapped you've taken away the
d8 Square from the black queen and if
you play something like Rook to E4
attacking the White Queen uh look at
this queen captures an E4 beautiful
stuff Knight captures and Bishop to C7
now again uh traps the black queen or
rather wins back the queen you're gonna
capture on B5 or somewhere after some B5
and you continue this position uh where
black is up upon okay white spawn
structure is a little bit messed up but
white is up the exchange so definitely
better position for white so instead
bookish played Rook to D5 very nice move
now you can again bring the queen back
to d8 and the Magnus plays a bishop
captures C6 looks a bit weird not
waiting for the bishop to be provoked by
A6 maybe improve the position uh a
little bit first but of course Magnus
thought of that and since he played it I
guess we have to listen to Magnus so
Bishop captures on C6 Queen captures and
now Pawn to B3 uh we have Rook back to
d8 and now Bishop to H4 uh Queen to D5
now again putting more pressure on this
um at B4 Pawn also on the B3 Pawn if the
Knight here moves so Rook F to E1 now
what's uh the idea behind this move uh
can you can you play Bishop captures on
C5 that is the real question here and
why would you do it well if you capture
here then Rook captures on C5 what if
you capture on B3 is this anything yes
you want a pawn but your Pawn structure
will get ruined Bishop can't respawn
captures Rook H5 and already it's black
who will be under attack which is
something you don't want so here glucose
plays B6 chases away the Knight with
knights the E4 uh Magnus down to 10
minutes on the clock wukash has some
half an hour on the clock and he plays
Bishop to B7 and now look at this bishop
Queen going after that G2 Pawn this is a
dream position for gukash I believe that
uh if glucose was offered to play this
position before the first move was even
played that he would accept it that I
mean he does have excellent winning
chances here the the queen combo is
excellent he does have the bishop there
no apparent weaknesses in the position
and uh Magnus plays Bishop captures on
F6
now here Magnus played it because he
it's not just a good move but also if
Lucas plays for example G characters and
f60 if he wants to keep the bishop pair
on the board then Magnus can force a
draw and uh by doing so win the match
Rook to C7 attack the two Bishops and
now after Rook to D7 he plays Knight to
C3 and the queen is in uh sort of a
Perpetual Queen hunt King to the queen
to the sixth night the B5 attacks the
queen queen D5 Knights the C3 and so on
you will force a Perpetual here so after
Bishop captures an F6 Bishop captures on
F6 has to be played and now Magnus plays
Knight captures on F6 which check and
ruins Booker's queen king side with G
captures and F6 and queen to E3 now
Magnus down to five minutes and he still
needs to make 11 more moves to reach
time control gookish has some 23 minutes
on the clock and he goes to Rook 8 to C8
and now uh we have H3 by Magnus also a
nice idea is Queen F4 stopping Queen to
F5 but he doesn't mind that and gookish
plays it of course Queen to F5 Knights
the a still trying to re-maneuver the
queen over to G4 wheeler where it will
put a lot of pressure on the black king
and while glucose could prevent this
with Ponte H5 he goes Queen to G5
instead he offers a queen trait here
tonight's the G4 and now King to G7
guarding the the df6 and the H6 squares
and here at Magnus plays Ponte A5 looks
like a weird move to play because he was
under five minutes on the clock but he
knows exactly what he's doing and this
is the top move recommended by the
engine he will either destroy Black's a
queen side if you capture then the ones
the pawns are completely ruined uh if
you play Queen captures then Queen to H6
will result in Checkmate so what can you
do here well the the only way for gukas
to keep the initiative going is Pawn to
H5 point being that after captures and
captures the Knight is still hanging and
after the night moves you will play Rook
captures on D4 and okay Rook captures
Bishop captures you will go to see one
with Tempo uh Rook to D5 now attacks the
Knight and one once we trade here let's
say capture some b6a captures and
knights the C4 you will play Rook to C5
and he keeps the the tension going with
some threads of Pawn to B5
uh but okay after A5 Queen captures an
E3 was played a gookish trades queens
and now Knight captures on E3 Magnus
doesn't play F characters on E3 this
seemingly stops Rook captures on e4 but
his position will be a bit more passive
uh because B captures an A5 okay the
pawn structure is messed up but uh it's
still up a pawn in in an end game and
after you try to bring the Knight into
the game then let's say Rook captures on
C1 Rook captures and Rook to see a
trades off everything captures captures
and you have a bishop and the Knight
being a bishop against the Knight being
up a pawn so it will be gookers fighting
for the win here though Magnus cannot
allow this he plays Knight captures on
E3 and okay Rook captures on D4 and now
Rook captures on C8 Bishop captures and
now Rook to C1 it's much easier to play
with uh of course The Rook still being
on the board Bishop to D7 and now Rook
the C7 putting pressure on the A7 Pawn B
captures on A5 Rook captures on A7 and
now Pawn to a for trading off everything
on the queen side beat characters with
Bishop captures and now Magnus just
plays Rook to A5 and here we have this
position where gookish is up a pawn but
it's four against three on the king's
side and it's not gonna be easy to
convert this but of course
is the one that we'll have to try if
he's the beat Magnus with black and
force tie breaks so here we have King to
G6 and the G4 by Magnus Bishop to C6 and
Rook the C5 attacks the bishop with
Bishop to E4 and now King to H2 so how
can guish win this well uh not not
easily okay he does have the the bishop
here but uh okay a G4 has been played
and unless uh you you can imagine a
position where the king comes to H4 and
The Rook somehow checkmates the Y King
uh you're not gonna win by Chuck mate so
maybe uh you know the more you trade
down the easier it's going to be to hold
this for Magnus so uh the basically you
win this by playing the absolute
strongest move every move until the end
of the game and you hope that Magnus
doesn't so Rook to D3 uh we have came to
G3 and now Pawn on the F5 uh Magnus
plays King to F4 we have Pawn to F6 and
now G captures on F5 with check Bishop
captures and now Knight captures on F5
we have e captures on F5 and now Pawn to
F3 and okay now gokish is still up a
pawn but it's a doubled F Pawn and not
much to play for here Rook the D4 check
was played King to G3 with King to G5
and now Rook the C2 we have Pawn to H5
uh trying to put pressure on magnus's
King but just Rook to A2 with kiponte
for with check King to G2 and now King
to H4 so glucose did win a lot of space
with his King here on the king side but
if you cannot kick away the white king
you cannot win the pawns here and as
long as this Rook is controlling the
second rank you can never kick away the
white king and that's a problem for
gookish even though Magnus does not
believe in fortresses he created one for
himself here uh King to H2 not this is
not objectively a fortress a fortress
would mean that one player is
significantly done on material and the
other player is able to hold an end game
due to a fortress but this is uh not uh
well literally a fortress so Rook to D7
we have rooked the B2 and now rooked the
D3 trying something but just King to G2
we have King to G5 gookers will try to
circle around with the King but just
Rook B5 check we have F5 Rook goes back
to B2 of course not allowing any checks
King to F6 and now Pawn to H4 uh taking
away the G5 Square from Gooker skin and
with the spawn guarding E4 and this
spawn guarding G5 that's all there is to
this game if you cannot deliver check
and your king cannot approach uh there
is no way to even try for a win here
King T5 was played King to F2 and it was
in this position and move 59 that the
players agreed to a draw as there is
nothing more to be done here so that's
it
lost the first game he draws the second
one and that means Magnus Carlsen is
through to the semi-finals where he will
face none other than ninjat abbasov who
we've just seen how he he completely
crushed with it with that London system
so it's going to be incredible Magnus
Carlsen versus the Dark Horse
of in the semi-finals of the video World
Cup uh it's gonna be very very
interesting so the other games were
still being played while I was recording
this uh once they are done I will
probably show them as it seems that we
will have a lot of decisive games at
this round
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed the big congratulations to the
magnet stuff break for gookish uh but
what are you gonna do uh you know he who
faces Magnus uh uh often perishes
uh so yeah I would like to thank uh
Serena was Kasha Yoon young Mario and
sinosa Michael shui and David Kimura for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here and thank you for watching
and I will see you soon continuing the
coverage of defeated World Cup uh until
it finishes uh so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day